facendo i ragazzi blog in questa camera
dove voi ricordate insomma tutte le cose
belle del canale dai tempi perché questa
camera ha visto e sentito cose che
nessuno dovrebbe sentire tranne
giampiero che montevideo questa camera
anche per me pregna di cose che hanno
caratterizzato la mia infanzia tra cui
le carte le figurine figurini pazzo per
sé figurine pazzo e siccome negli ultimi
anni non so anzi l'ultimo anno non so
per quale arcano motivo sono ritornati
vivo dalle carte dei pokémon che io
colleziono quando avevo 5 anni non
ridere il motivo del perché riesplosa st
moda dei pokémon comunque ho ritirato
fuori le carte che ho attualmente perché
io la volevo collezionato chissà dove
sono finite però quelle che ho
attualmente posso mostrarvele sono cielo
qua adesso ve le faccio vedere vi mostro
che cosa questo questo è il video in
questione di vostro cosa mi è rimasto in
tutto questo tempo di scommettere del
telefono cominciamo con il buon malki ha
ex che non ho idea del perché sia perché
comunque non sono in ordine di
importanza e queste sono tutte rare e
ottenuto solo quelle stelline
praticamente reggi gas ex normale non mi
ricordo che si chiama perché quando
uscità st generazione già non giocavo
più e ha bisogno di tipo di dirvi
ragazzi che alcune carte che possiedono
solo in giapponese perché avevo gustato
non so se vi ricordate i tempi quando
avevamo fatto lo scartamento dei
pacchetti in giappone sono passati
secoli ormai e quindi alcune sono in
giapponese tipo sue cure tipo anni o
forse è un po speed perché c'è un sacco
di cose da fare dei ragazzi la chicca
arriva tra poco non sono neanche al
carte dei pokémon la chicca sta per
arrivare però vabbè tanto andiamo avanti
le regioni sono un'idea ma oltretutto i
giapponesi tra l'altro questo è un bel
gary dos garth comp usciamo dal
giapponese no come non detto ritornato
ne ho un po di carine ma la cosa più
di tutto questo
vado avanti non so perché adesso le
faccio di tutto non sono tantissime e
che sono quasi tutte della generazione
che è che io conosco alla fine perché
sapevo io tranne willie walsh i wish i
was non lo è la cosa che mi ha sempre
più di più scombussolato sono le carte
quelle dove ci sono due pokémon insieme
tipo gardev aires come cup dice
produzione di dvd
quando io già non seguivo più pokémon e
mi farò mettere strano sa cosa comunque
cobario gx qui si fa sì che coltiva
spuntare male si vede che il mio poche
poi c'è ulivi che si è incastrato qua in
mezzo non si sa con un fiore sono
allergico i tra l'ex questa è fatta
veramente bene ragazzi anche proprio
bello da sentire proprio ruvida questa è
proprio bella poli qualcosa dark rai
molto figo c'è anche dark mediaset
lancia questo anche se cliccate in mezzo
dal fa un po schifo blasio questo e nido
king in giapponese questo non so cosa
sia ma è un lampadario va bene lo so che
i fanatici di pokémon mista di sangue
dalle orecchie ragazzi ho smesso di
allora ho smesso di seguire con
attenzione perché quello secco anche con
poche mondo eccetera però con attenzione
ho smesso di servire pokémon nel alla
terza generazione ma sono comunque
sempre fan quello senza ombra di dubbio
anziani volta vi do delle bustine
vivendo a comprarle anche se non conosco
le generazioni comunque mag nathan
questo è il set ex editore molto figo
perché è giapponese ma venduto scrivere
comunque il nome e non so per quale
cacchio di motivo però la bene ed è
bellissimo ma un doppione di gary dos
andiamo avanti per tunes affissi a
questi eccessi
questo è un sarcofago va bene ma nati a
questo tutte le tre evoluzioni di char
isaf tra cui lui ovviamente pg ott ex a
questa questa teatro in orizzontale sa
cosa penso
vabbè cioè nella mi nella mia idea di
carte non esiste venosa all ex questo è
un bel niente male ente gli ex anche
questa carina in italiano
questo è un acquisto e un altro di
c'è ormai non ce l'ho più però capisco
la potenza dal fatto che compra una
carta orizzontale e gli orizzontale di
carte non si vedono
questi sono informato stories e questo
sia informato youtube praticamente ok
knew too much
questo è un pezzo di carta a metà non è
che l'hanno tranciato chi sta volando
questo video non colleziona più carte di
foto non sappiate che ci sono anche
carte che vanno composte adesso
incredibile come la soes niente male tra
l'altro un altro bene usar cielo doppio
e poi arriviamo a rayquaza ex p geo tex
e poi detto è 30 persone mie carte
attualmente quelle che possiedo talmente
rare adesso non andiamo a vedere come
tutte le carte che ho perché sennò
diventiamo pazzi volevo anche passare a
altri giochi di carte che da piccolo ho
collezionato quindi queste qua ve lo
faccio vedere nel dettaglio le altre le
faccio vedere qual è la webcam
allora abbiamo tra l'altro i mazzi che
io possiedo sono tutti all'interno di
questi deck fighissimi tra cui mio
preferito è questo questi ragazzi e il
buono yuki per chi conoscesse yu gi oh
le faccio vedere d'acqua perché tanto
queste passano molte di meno e poi
quella non superare quindi queste
faccende da qua abbiamo il cyber drago
finale che era una delle mete preferite
in assoluto di hugh di oggi era
veramente splendida e poi quando li
giappone quando sabato in giappone ho
comprato avevo acquistato poi ci sono
anche i ancora il prezzo ign sta cosa
finisce a 750 iene 605 tagli anche sono
tipo è questa costa tipo 5 euro e
qualcosa questa è un po meno tipo quasi
5 euro che questa e sono due divinità
tgx mi pare no perché c'è una divinità
divinità egizia e quella di yoko
l'originale e poi c'era un credibile
dopodiché abbiamo un'altra le carte che
ho sempre adorato un sacco queste le
prime le primissime rovinata ragazzi
però purtroppo negli anni miglia e già
un miracolo che ce l'ho ancora e poi c'è
tutto il mio deck che non vi faccio
vedere perché non è che sia
incredibile cioè non ci sono carte rate
le carte che io do lavori più in
assoluto tipo il copiatore che infatti
poi ho iniziato a farlo anch'io compiti
fa quando ero alle elementari giravano
tra i bambini anche le carte al mercato
nero delle carte cioè tali scambi valide
c'erano c'erano anche le carte tarocche
ovviamente io ero riuscito a procurarmi
questa ed ero fieri siamo ai tempi che è
tanto e tutto è rovinata dark master che
dovrebbe essere studiata ricchissimo in
posizione da superman non si vede più
perché un po sbiadito va all'attacco e
infinito difesa infinito è ovviamente
libertà rock e anche dal retro si vedono
queste carte qua quando ero piccolo le
scambiavano tutte tutte le e poi c'era
anche drago alato dirà anche questo
piper tarocco schiava helios 0 saur va
bene passiamo all'ultimo gioco di carte
prima di passare alle figurine e lì c'è
da divertirsi che è due masters 2 il
masters è un gioco di carte che si sono
pagati in due io e chi l'ha fatto noi
rata in italia non era molto conosciuto
penso che all'estero si limiterà lo
davano su cartoon network ordo due
master sarà questo questo ragazzo shobu
che rifugga mi ricordo anche il nome che
è insomma doveva aveva questo drago bosh
che l'asta carta bellissima era un po
new york punto zero per fare a breve le
carte erano fatte così e io ne andavo
fierissimo diste cacchio di carte
veramente finché purtroppo le
collezionavano veramente in pochissimi
in due
forse il gioco di carte che più mi ha
dato emozioni perché poi anche giocarlo
questo gioco di carte qui anche giocarlo
e rab per ragazzi era incredibile
egli ci divertiva coi miei amici ci
divertiamo tantissimo davvero e quindi è
sempre passato un po in secco queste
loro è sempre passato un po inosservato
2 massas in italia a quanto pare perché
non l'ho mai sentito troppo ma meritava
tantissimo ma passiamo invece al
penultimo album di oggi che
si tratta dell'album degli album dei
calciatori panini
ok e questi sono gli ultimi due ma
questo questo era il mio originale cioè
originale nel senso anche gli ex in
originale ma era il mio il primo album
di figurine
come potete vedere 2003 2004 ero
piccolissimo anche quello 2005 2006 non
era male effettivamente vi prego ho
scritto anche delle robe ho attaccato
una figura di gilardino qua davanti e
poi lorenzo studi 95 centrocampista
maglia numero 10 non è vero quando la
juventus capito il preferito francesco
totti cancellato francesco strano questo
video non so perché l'ho cancellato
probabilmente perché qualcuno mi ha
detto mentre ero piccolo per come ha
detto ronaldinho ronaldinho
e allora ho scritto ronaldinho sotto
scritto sbagliatissimo da con la jeep
djavan la juve avevo quasi completata
tra l'altro non era niente male c'è il
bamboo fun con un sacco di capelli
thuram cannavaro grava p ha perso otto
chili a chiellini come cioè come è
possibile tutto ciò
arriviamo al pezzo finale che la mia il
fiore all'occhiello di tutta la
collezione che è ovviamente bravo cose
forse già fatto vedere ma è la
collezione di cui vado più fiero l'album
di dragon ball e la micardi da un ball z
migliore perché è quella completa c'è
effettivamente l'unico album che ho
completo che adesso non lo apro per bene
perché sono faccio un disastro però
diciamo che c'è veramente di tutto
e la cosa che mi ha più colpito di
questo e che ci ho messo veramente
tantissimo per completarlo ragazzi
dicono che ci avevo messo un'infinità di
tempo anzi alcune carte sono pure
cascate aquile dovrei di posizionare
però ci sono praticamente tutte l'altro
non so se vi ricordate draw my life con
il non azzardatevi a toccare il mio goku
ragazzi sono passati mille anni 1600
anni c'è ancora il profumo le lamincards
non va mai via cioè pazzesco questa era
la mia collezione di figurine mi fa
piacere che siano tornati di moda le
carte di poche ma adesso non so ben
capire
il perché non sarà magari perché logan
poi ci ha fatto un video della speso
milioni di dollari non un'idea
probabilmente quello però mamma mia che
roba signori spero che vi sia piaciuto
come io mi piace anche alla ricerche
come livido tutta la descrizione e se
non sarà così ti schianti come sempre
noi ci rivediamo ad un prossimo vito
belle ragazze
[Musica]